foreign
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar forensic screening 101 getting
the most out of lcms
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by psyx
to learn more visit syex.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Carl
ochen PhD senior scientist at psyx Carl
you may now begin your presentation
thank you so today we're going to be
talking about forensics and the way I
kind of set this talk up is to really
just be talking about where lcms fits
into sort of a forensics workflow
so when we think about uh lcms or mass
spectrometry really any analytical sort
of lab test in the forensic setting
we're probably pretty familiar with
things like NCIS
um or that say in Breaking Bad when they
mention they have to run the sample on a
gas chromatographer Mass spectrometer
and I think that's probably the only
time we hear someone say that unless
you're giving a tour to the accounting
department but in sort of these settings
uh they'll get a sample run it in a
matter of seconds and know who created
it what it was created from where it
came from and all of the above and
obviously that's not super realistic
but mass spectrometry does sort of give
us those answers
um just not not as easily as it's made
to seem on the TV show
um so what are we trying to do here
so we're really trying to answer a
question
um and in the forensics question or
setting these questions just differ a
little bit so we may be trying to answer
you know what is this drug we may be
screening
um serum whole blood for poisons we may
be looking at accelerants uh we're just
trying to figure out the answer to a
question we're asking
and in Mass spectrometry we're going to
do that or answer that question by using
fingerprints but we're going to use
chemical fingerprints so we're going to
be looking at things like fragments
parent masses to figure out you know is
this cocaine or is this just baking soda
but regardless
um when we talk about lcms or really any
sort of mass spectrometry type workflow
uh you know it's going to depend a
little bit what our goals are and what
our goals are or what we're trying to
accomplish is going to depend what
workflow we sort of choose so I'm going
to be talking a lot about sort of this
suspect screening or more screening type
workflows but if we think about sort of
the most simple question we can ask with
a lcms system where it's
really just our compounds XYZ present so
this might be something that you're
doing now but certainly something you're
familiar with we're looking you know is
THC present in this
cookie sample so these are the things
that we refer to as our known gnomes we
know we want to look for them we know
what they are
versus in sort of this more uh
larger rather uh sort of suspect
screening workflow where we're really
asking the question you know are these
compounds present from this list so an
example of this might be let's say
fentanyl analogs we're not asking the
question anymore is fentanyl present
we're saying hey I know these analogs
exist I might not have standards for
them but I know they're masses I have
some Library Spectrum are they present
in my sample
and then sort of the most complicated or
the the biggest question we can ask is
just simply what's in my sample so these
would be sort of the known unknowns and
our unknown unknowns so this might be
everything from drugs to Natural
Products Etc so we're moving up that
list and getting to some really really
complex data so we don't know what we
don't know essentially but when we're
talking about suspect screening or
non-target analysis A really target
analysis there are a couple things we
kind of have to think about
first would be Mass accuracy um so I'll
just take a second to sort of introduce
some of these terms just in the off
chance you're not familiar with them
um but we're going to talk a lot about
them
so what is mass accuracy Mass accuracy
is just the accurate mess so that's the
observed Mass so that's the mass you
measured you know maybe you measured out
on a q trap or on a q-top that's that
mass that you saw versus the exact Mass
so that's the calculated mass of an ion
so let's say you have I'll go back to
cocaine you have the formula for that
compound so what is the mass or what
should the mass have then
and the difference between these values
ends up being the mass accuracy
so typically we report this in parts per
million or PPM and on an accurate math
system we'd really expect that mass
accuracy to be you know less than 5 PPM
ideally less than two
but on a nominal Mass system we're
talking about a difference of you know
0.7 Daltons so instead of 0.0001 uh
Dalton's we're talking about 0.7 so that
mass accuracy is is going to be much
much higher
the next sort of really important topic
um that we need to kind of discuss is
resolution so resolution is just simply
that accurate Mass
divided by the the Peak at half maximum
and if we compare this to a nominal Mass
system which is really what I want to
kind of show
um
We Get Much More highly defined Peaks so
we have more resolution we can see hey
there's actually two potentially two
different compounds hidden underneath
that nominal Mass Spectrum
and if we just had that nominal Mass
Spectrum to rely on you know it might be
really difficult to see what we're
looking at so we sacrifice some of that
mass accuracy that doesn't mean though
that we can't use a nominal Mass system
for some of these screening workflows
and if we bring it all the way back to
you know kind of what are we actually
doing so when we're talking about sort
of finding a compound's molecular
fingerprints or its fragmentation
pattern
um regardless of what sort of question
we're doing we're going to be doing some
sort of msms analysis so the most common
workflow would be sort of a targeted
approach so you've probably heard of it
referred to as an mrm approach and in
this scenario we're going to isolate
with our first quadrupole for a specific
ion so this would be the parent
and let's say that's 2 15. so we're
going to filter everything else out and
just allow that 215 ion to pass through
into Q2 and in Q2 is where some
fragmentation will take place so we're
creating those daughter ions or
fragments
those fragments will then enter Q3 and
when they enter your Q3 we're going to
do the same thing we did with our q1 and
filter for a specific ion so we've gone
from a parent to a daughter I'm or a
product to a fragment and if we think
about that that's that's being really
specific so we've got a lot of really
valuable information there
this would be on a triple quadrupole how
does it look if we're comparing that to
maybe a qtop instrument
so for a q-top instrument
we're really doing the same thing we're
going to talk about how we select for
that q1 or that parent Mass rather but
regardless we're going to
select for a specific parent
that parent is going to make its way
into the Collision cell
fragmentation is going to take place so
we're going to create those fragments
for those daughter ions if we're doing
an mrm experiment we can even optimize
that CE but there's a little bit of a
difference here so all of those ions are
going to enter our top analyzer
and the way I like to describe a top
analyzer is it's a really really good
stopwatch and a really good measuring
tape so over the years we've gotten
really good at knowing how long it takes
something to happen
and we have a really accurate way of
measuring a distance so what we can do
is basically correlate the time it takes
for those ions to reach our detector to
their Mass
and that allows us to be highly specific
with our Master it essentially allows us
to have that really high mass accuracy
so that's great
um but how do we kind of fit into those
workflows we were talking about earlier
so if you have a nominal math system
um you can do some of these more
advanced workflows but if you have a
triple quad system you're really kind of
limited to that traditional
quantification
I'm not going to talk a whole lot about
that in terms of forensics but we're
going to talk a lot about that
multi-target screening so this would be
a workflow that you could do if you had
say a qtop system or even a q-trap
system so it's sort of the nominal
versus the high resolution
and before I move on to the next couple
slides there's one thing I always want
to kind of be upfront with
um because it's a question that gets
asked a lot and that is how are we
confident in our data so you're going to
hear me using a lot of terms like level
two level three
um and these are just sort of confidence
intervals
so back in 2004
um the MSI initiative took place and
during that time we basically decided we
needed some way to communicate how
confident we were in an ID
whether that be to other scientists or
primarily other scientists reviewers Etc
and since then we've moved on we've got
more sort of uh
Advanced with how we sort of communicate
this
typically we'll end up using something
called the shamansky index and all that
is is just from level five to level one
you know how confident are we in our ID
so level one would be We've ran a
standard versus a level five where we
just have an exact Mass
and the reason we even have to talk
about that is that there's a lot of
compounds and there's a lot of data to
go through
so
um I'll sometimes get asked by folks who
maybe don't have a ton of experience in
the space you know why don't you just
look for everything
that would be the easiest option right
and if we think about pubchem there's
nearly 100 million compounds uh in Pub
chem why not just screen them all
and we technically could
um it would take a while right uh but we
have some pieces of information that
we're going to use to make this a lot
faster so instead of you know going
through and looking at you know
we were analyzing a cookie sample for
um let's say drugs of abuse
it really wouldn't make sense to screen
that sample with
the hmdb database for example they or
you know to screen it for microcysteines
that's really not relevant so we're
going to use some software tricks
um and then just some some good analysts
or best practices to kind of limit the
amount of time we're spending doing
these screening workflows
because if we look at the number of
compounds present it's a little
overwhelming and if we look at kind of
the mass range of where those compounds
sit they're all in the range that are
really relevant for forensics so in that
small molecule range
so let's go ahead and do that so let's
start with our nominal math system so
we're going to be doing an MRI to Epi
scan and we'll talk about what that
means
but first things first we're going to do
an mrm experiment so just like I showed
earlier we're monitoring for a specific
parent
creating some fragments and then we're
monitoring or we're monitoring for that
fragment rather
and what we're then doing is deciding if
it meets a certain intensity threshold
so in this case let's say it doesn't
need an intensity threshold it's going
to go ahead and do that memorandum
experiment all over again
versus let's say in that red Peaks case
it does meet that intensity threshold so
that dotted blue line so in that case
we're going to do an Epi experiment
and this Epi experiment is essentially
going to give us that molecular
fingerprint
but how does it work and what does it
look like
so Epi stands for enhanced product ion
and it's going to work pretty similar to
a traditional mrm experiment in the
sense that we are going to isolate or
filter out
compounds that we're not interested in
so in this case we're only interested in
that 215 again so that 215 is going to
pass through our first quadrupole is
going to enter
the Collision cell and from there
there's going to be fragmentation that
takes place but here's where it differs
from that mrm experiment I showed
earlier
instead of using the quadrupole to
filter out for a specific ion we're
actually going to allow those ions to
fill up in the linear ion trap and then
make their way to the detector and from
there we're going to actually have a
compound's fingerprint
which is all good and great but why does
that even matter and how would you use
that sort of in a forensic setting or a
screening method and I've got some data
here uh and the question I was asking
was you know I was looking for phenoxy
carb
and at first I was just doing a
traditional mrm sort of workflow
and what you'll notice that in my Matrix
sample well there's a pretty big peak
there and in my QC sample there's a peak
for phenoxy carb and they're at slightly
different retention times but I'm not
overly confident that that isn't phenoxy
carbon in my Matrix sample maybe there
was something odd or off with the
injection
maybe add a little bit of LC issues
maybe my column has some retention time
drift who knows but based on the ion
ratio I wouldn't be super confident in
saying there's definitely no phenoxy
carb in my major example
and that's where that Epi data becomes
really valuable
up top I have my Matrix sample and on
the right hand side I have my
fragmentation pattern
down below I have my QC or let's just
referred to it as a reference standard
and I've got my fragmentation pattern
down there as well
and the first thing you'll notice is
that well those fragmentation patterns
don't look anything alike
so not only do I have a different
retention time
um but I have essentially a different
molecular fingerprint so I would never
confuse these two things with this data
set that can be very very very confident
now that yeah you know I did not detect
any phenox carb in my sample that Peak
is is not a phenoxy carbon
and this fits really nicely into
forensics workflows so here's an example
we've got 98 drugs we're doing sort of
the same sort of gradient you would with
an mrm experiment and we are triggering
that Epi data when necessary you know
presumably in these samples we're not
going to have 98 hits so we can make
these really big lists of compounds to
screen for
and that's awesome so with the q-trap
instrument we can do this
but we can also do this with a accurate
Mass instrument
so it's a little bit different
but it it's kind of the same so with a
q-top the first thing we're always going
to do is a tough Ms and I'd refer to
this as a survey scan so we're going to
be looking at that ms1 data
essentially we're going to be looking at
the parent masses so those masses are
going to pass through q1 we're not going
to use q1 to filter anything out
we're going to let them pass through the
Collision cell there's going to be no
fragmentation that takes place they're
going to make their way into the top
analyzer and make their way to the
detector and from there we'll get their
Mass we'll get you know their isotopic
information we'll get their intensity et
cetera without any fragmentation data
yet
so when we collect that fragmentation
data we kind of have a couple options to
choose from
and it's going to depend a little bit on
what you want to accomplish
so let's take a Ida method so I didn't
mention it earlier but
um the qtrap or the mrm Epi example was
really an Ida method we gave it some
sort of information
versus something like uh an information
independent acquisition type so at psyx
we use swath so that's called some
cultural windowed acquisition of all
theoretical fragments but essentially
all that means is we're not really
giving it any information
and what does that look like and how do
you use that data
well for information dependent
acquisition
it's just like it sounds we're giving
some sort of information so we're saying
if that compound contains or in rather
if in our survey Spectra we see uh this
neutral loss then I want you to do this
and typically that then is always msms
so we're going to create some
fragmentation
so it could be a neutral loss it could
be an intensity value which is what it
normally most of the time at least is so
if that parent Peak is above a thousand
CPS then I want you to collect msms data
on it
here we've got an example of sort of
that top Ms data so
um I refer to this as you know a total
ion chromatogram or here we can just say
uh it's our ms1 data no fragmentation
has taken place and I set my intensity
Threshold at three and a half e to the 5
CPS
so basically any Peaks above this line
I'm going to collect msms data on
and that's exactly what the qtop will do
so it will collect data on these four
compounds and we'll get our
fragmentation data that we can then
screen against the library and
interrogate and however we see fit
so that's great
um typically we choose the top 10 to 12
candidates that gives us pretty good
coverage
but we've essentially biased our data in
some way so
when we do information independent
acquisition we're we're telling it hey
it has to be above this threshold or it
must meet this criteria which
can be great it gives you really high
quality Spectra which is awesome
but you know when we're doing these sort
of all-encompassing screening workflows
and it's definitely when we're doing
these non-target analysis type workflows
you know our goal is to try to eliminate
bias as much as possible
we can't obviously do that we've
introduced bias just by choosing to run
the sample on an LCM SMS instead of a GC
for or we've you know decided to do uh
ESI instead of apci so there's always
going to be some bias but we want to
limit it as much as possible
and that's where approaches like swath
become pretty valuable so data
independent acquisition
and swath sounds kind of complicated but
it's really pretty simple
so for swap analysis I like to describe
it as a sliding window
so let's take our first msms experiment
all we're doing is we are allowing ions
between the mass of 100 m over Z and 820
in this case movz to pass through q1
they're fragmented and they're red on
our top analyzer where we're going to
get masses intensities Etc
and then we're going to move that window
so that window is going to move and now
any Ion with uh M over Z from 120 to 140
is going to pass through q1 enter Q2
fragmentation takes place and again
we're going to look at those fragments
via our top analyzer so we'll have all
that good accurate Mass data on them
and swallowish is going to move through
so it's just going to move through each
one of these windows and this is
happening you know in fractions of a
second so a typical sort of swath method
the cycle time is usually it's under a
second 0.8 or so depending on the number
of windows so we're we're going through
that range and we're collecting all that
data
and that's awesome
um but we can even be more specific with
it
so you may find yourself and I certainly
have in a scenario where we have these
fixed windows so I showed from 100 to
120 for example in this case let's do
steps of 25.
and what happens if you have two
compounds that you know have the same
mass or very similar mass rather and you
just for whatever reason you can't
separate them via chromatography they
allude at exactly the same time you know
if they alluded at you know even a
fraction different uh retention time
software can detect that and we can use
some tools to de-convolute it but
this is the worst case scenario it's the
exact same time
that's where variable Windows come into
play
so let's take this example so instead of
having a window from 174 to 200 or
essentially a fixed width of 26 Daltons
what if we had a variable with so we can
adjust that and why would that matter
so here I have an example of MDA
and up top we have our variable windows
and down below we have our fixed and
what you'll kind of immediately notice
is even though uh you know we're looking
at a small Mass window of 26 Daltons
we've got another Peak
and it's chromatographically separated
so you might say this is not an issue
but why not eliminate it completely
avoid sort of any accidents that can
happen with integration
um we can just get rid of it using those
variable windows and the same can be
said if we look at what the other Peak
is so MDMA we've got that MDMA Peak
showing up we could potentially Mis
integrate it but in our variable Windows
we're just looking at the compound we're
interested in so a nice and elegant way
to sort of eliminate a problem that
doesn't need to exist
so just kind of as a recap before we we
dive a little bit further uh into the
types of sort of these high-res
applications we have things like swath
um and Ida the differences here are
we're looking at sort of a wider window
with swath acquisition versus Ida where
we're looking at a specific ion and then
compare that to something like you know
an MSL where we're looking at the entire
uh fragmentation of everything at that
moment so that can be very complex so
the way I have it organized here is you
know how complex is your data set
and each serves a different purpose
so just as a recap we're selecting for a
specific ion in this case 215 because
it's either maybe in my window or it
triggered an intensity threshold
it's passing through its entry in Q2 we
have optimize CES if we want to quantify
or if we're just doing a screening
method we can just let those fragments
pass through at a sort of standard
Collision energy be read by the detector
and then we can use them to do our
analysis so it doesn't really matter
whether you chose an information
dependent approach or a data independent
approach
the fragmentation mechanisms and
everything past that q1 is essentially
exactly the same
so why does it matter um which one you
choose and really how would you choose a
certain approach
and it depends a little bit on you know
what kind of questions you're asking and
what the goal is
um if you're screening something like a
library uh swath you know Ida both work
really well one of the things that I
like to kind of
show it as an example of why a data
independent approach sometimes can be
super valuable
is in the case of data archival
um so if you imagine let's say worst
case scenario uh we did not collect some
msms data using our information
dependent acquisition approach because
it did not mean our intensity threshold
it happens maybe we set that value too
high and that means we just don't have
that data it just doesn't exist so we
have to rerun that sample
now if we ran that same sample using
swath it doesn't matter what that
intensity threshold was we always have
that msms data so I like to think of it
as kind of like this digital way to
freeze your sample
so an example I use is you know back in
the day when I was in grad school uh we
had this data set and a colleague in my
you know we had this very specific
question we're looking for fluorinated
compounds
um in this data set
and we found them we identified them uh
and we moved on but that data set still
existed so a few years later a grad
student came in with a completely
different question they were looking at
the hydrocarbon person or hydrocarbon
portion and they went through and
identified all those hydrocarbons so
they didn't need to reacquire they
didn't need to have that sample present
that data existed so you can go back and
query it and where that becomes
interesting is if you think about maybe
like a a public health study where you
know all of a sudden you're starting to
see this compound appear in the
population
well if you acquire using something like
swath you could technically go back in
time and say you know when did this
compound first appear was it there 10
years ago eight years ago Etc so that
can be really cool
but regardless both are good approaches
um and certainly work really well for
suspect screening
so let's kind of move into the workflow
and how this data is being processed
so for suspect screening we're creating
a list or we have a list we're going
through that list and we're using
approaches to sort of filter things out
so we're matching to exact class we're
matching to the isotopic pattern uh then
we're using that fragmentation data and
then we're adding a probable compound so
we're moving up our pyramid
and if we think about it you know we're
starting out in a scenario where we just
have an exact mass and our goal is to
climb up our pyramid to either this gray
Zone where we think we have an idea what
the structure is
um or more likely we're trying to get or
we'll end up in that sort of level two
if we do have a library so the
difference between you know whether you
get to the gray zone or that green sort
of probable structure is if you're
screening a library versus only using a
list
so what do these lists look like
um so they're a lot of different types
of lists
um but really all you need is a mass
so as long as you have a mass you can
screen your data set
and when you do that you can look for
specific compounds or compound classes
in a perfect world you'd also want to
have that formula and usually you do so
you can go through and see if that
isotopic information makes sense
from there you
really want some sort of spectral
library and there are a lot of different
types of spectral libraries
so for example you know obviously if
size has a library that's combined with
nist
um but there are other libraries that
you can sort of look at
um mono is a great one but you can look
at sort of In-House libraries too so if
you have sort of a let's say you're
looking at synthetic cannabinoids and
you've run a bunch of Standards or you
and your colleagues have that would be a
great example of an in-source or
in-house library that you can share
so let's go ahead and say you did have
that Library you went through you
screened we're going to be using that
mass error so in this scenario we're
saying yes that Mass area looks good
we're going to be using that isotope
ratio So based on the formula since it's
in the library we have the formula does
the isotope ratio make sense and then
does that msms data match
if all those things are great we can be
happy and we can move on
but this is kind of the perfect case
scenario right
um whether you're using a q-trap or
you're using a accurate math system
there could be times where you're
looking for a compound that isn't
present in the library at least not one
that you have access to
um so what do you do then and sort of
how do you approach that
so there are a bunch of different
options
um you can search at other libraries
obviously so in this example you know
I'm looking at a fluorochemical library
but it doesn't really matter you can be
looking at a forensics Library
um but there's also databases right we
talked about it earlier uh in terms of
pubchem there's 100 million compounds in
pubchem how do you sort of use that data
to get yourself into that level three
Zone
some of the tools I like to sort of
um show customers or at least introduce
the idea of using to would be things
like metfrag and then certainly CSI
finger ID so these are tools that
essentially were built to answer that
question so what do we do when we don't
have Spectra
and if we look at something like Sirius
which uses CSI finger ID this is
essentially a database and what the
folks there did was they went through
and they taught that database what the
fragmentation should be based on a
structure so they use machine learning
to take let's say
glucose they showed it the msms data and
it learned from that and now can go
through things like pubchem and say hey
based on the mass this is what I think
the parent is and based on the
fragmentation or based on the structure
rather this is what the predicted
fragmentation looks like and you can use
that data to then be you know more
confident or somewhat confident in your
result from there obviously you have
some more work to do you'd have to climb
up that pyramid and you know hopefully
purchase a standard but at least you'd
have a compound of interest that you can
then go ahead and say Yes I need to
purchase
uh methamphetamine so I can compare to
the Spectra I observed
so when you find yourself in that
scenario this is a good approach to sort
of move up that confidence pyramid
now you could say screening these
libraries is is good enough and that's
fine too it really depends on how deep
you want to go and what are the
questions you're trying to answer
but if we go back to sort of our
workflow map so multi-target screening
suspect screening
that makes a lot of sense
um we can go ahead and do those types of
workflows get those types of answers and
honestly that's probably going to be the
sort of Workhorse in a forensic setting
besides traditional quantification
obviously
but what if you wanted to get real fancy
um what if you had a question where you
didn't know what you're looking for you
just know something's different so let's
say you have a sample
and you're not sure what's in it you
screened your libraries nothing hit you
looked through pubchem there weren't any
matches maybe this is some sort of new
designer drug how would you go about
sort of screening your samples for
something like that
so in this scenario we're at the level
five and that's where we are
um so we only have an exact Mass
um we've got potentially hundreds of
them maybe even thousands of them
depending on how complex your sample is
how do we go about matching those masses
to a structure
so in non-target analysis
we are essentially doing two things for
it to be considered non-target analysis
the way we acquire the data has to be in
a type that is you know compatible with
non-target analysis so we could be doing
swath or Ida essentially we just cannot
be doing that mrm workflow so we cannot
be biasing our system by saying only
look for this transition for example
that wouldn't be appropriate
and then our Peak detection and this is
probably one of the more important parts
um
when we identify Peaks or we pull out
what features are
um we we can't be giving it any
information so in our suspect screening
examples we're looking at a list and
we're telling it to go look for these
compounds
here what we want our software to do is
essentially recognize anything that
resembles a peak
um you know obviously every different
vendor software every you know
third-party software does this a little
bit differently
um I'll just talk about sex OS but
um what we're relying on is you know is
it gaussian what's the intensity all of
those sort of variables the quality to
say yes these are these are my Peaks um
which I refer to as features so these
are these are all the features now I
need to go ahead and try to ID some of
them
so it's sort of a fun case study
um that I have was I was looking at some
samples with a colleague of mine and
these were some fentanyl samples
um and we were looking for Fentanyl
analogs
so in any type of non-target analysis
the most important thing is sort of how
are you going to interrogate that data
so you could have thousands of different
features how are you going to go about
actually pulling out what's important to
you so in this scenario in this case
study my colleague and I were asking the
question you know what fentanyl analogs
are present uh and we didn't we didn't
know
so we exhausted our list of suspected
ones
um but we wanted to go ahead and say are
any others present
so what we ended up doing is this
diagnostic iron filtering approach
so if we take fentanyl for example we
know there's some common fragments that
we would expect to observe that 105 at
188 those are pretty diagnostic to
Fentanyl so what if instead of querying
the MS data like we were with a suspect
screening approach what if we sort of
turned it on its head and we queried the
msms data
so in this scenario I'm really asking
the question are those fragments present
if so they are likely some sort of
fentanyl analog and that's what we did
so we went through queried our msms data
and we have essentially found a bunch of
these analogs that we didn't know
existed so these are unknown unknown to
us we didn't know they were there but we
used this approach to sort of tease them
out or pull them out of our data
so a cool example when we did that now
here's kind of what it looked like we
had several to then go through and you
can kind of see in the bottom right yep
we've got that 188 we've got that 105 we
talked about so we see those sort of
diagnostic ions
um but this was not the parent Mass
maybe I was expecting and certainly I
wasn't expecting this many
um different analogs to be present so
now it's kind of up to me to go through
this data and decide you know does this
make sense
um are these truly the compounds I'm
interested in and what to do about it
afterwards
so when I do that it was a pretty pretty
easy workflow we just made a component
list just like we were doing before we
say you know did we know them if we did
know them
we would add them to our library if they
weren't already present if we didn't we
do some structural elucidation to try to
figure out what that structure was and
then added to our library
so our goal is always to be moving
towards the more simpler workflows
when we're doing this non-target
analysis
essentially what we want to end up with
at the end of the day is this really
comprehensive Library that's our goal so
as we identify things
we're just going to continue to add them
to the library those will then be picked
up in our suspect screening approach and
we won't have to go to this more sort of
uh
time-consuming process of non-target
analysis
so there are a lot of different options
um for forensic screening it's going to
depend on the questions you're trying to
answer it's going to depend a little bit
on your equipment too are you working
with a nominal Mass instrument are you
working with an accurate Mass instrument
that will kind of change how you
approach your data sets and certainly
how you acquire the data but regardless
you can do these types of workflows
um now if you wanted to rely on those
libraries rely on those suspect lists to
figure out yes this is what I'm
interested in
and when we do that um I always like to
stop and you know think about what we're
trying to answer you know what is the
purpose of this data what am I going to
do with this data how far up that
confidence pyramid do I need to be and
in all cases you know if we're going to
use this for any sort of you know going
to quarter et cetera we need that
reference standard so we we need to
climb up our pyramid to get to that
confident yes this is what I'm looking
at
um but before then when we communicated
to internal colleagues when we are
deciding what standards we need to
purchase
um
getting to a level two getting a library
match
um that's super valuable it saves you
time you're no longer looking at just a
list or just a formula on a piece of
paper you have a suspected compound that
you can go out and purchase or maybe you
already have
so you know how good is good is enough
is going to really depend on what you're
doing and what the goals of either your
study or the purpose that you collected
that data
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions
great well thank you Carl for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar so if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
can you screen libraries collected on a
nominal Mass instrument on an accurac
math system
yeah yeah so
um that's a question I get asked uh
quite a bit where somebody has maybe
built up a really nice uh nominal Mass
library and they're moving into a
position where they're going to be
purchase purchasing say a qtop
um and they can certainly still screen
that data obviously you know there's
some sort of
the mass accuracy is going to differ
since it was collected in a unims
setting but it's still really valuable
information it can still be used to make
those positive IDs get you up to a level
two where you can then go ahead and
purchase a standard and then the great
part is once you purchase that standard
and confirmed yes that is what I'm
interested in it's easy enough to just
add that sort of accurate Mass Spectra
to your library and continue on and you
can skip that step
great thank you another question we have
here how much time does a screening
method take
yeah
um so good question and I assume you're
talking about
um processing the data when it you talk
about like sort of acquiring the data it
wouldn't take any longer than a
quantitation method unless you really
wanted to spread things out or had a
really complex sample
but when it comes to data processing uh
it definitely is a little more time
intensive than a quantitation workflow
that being said if you know the question
you're asking or what you're trying to
do is just screen a library
um it's not a lot more time
um it's it's pretty equivalent to sort
of if you're just building Cal curves
Etc there's really just a couple more
steps and thankfully software has gotten
to the point where you know it does most
of it for us
um so we don't have to spend a lot of
time sort of processing it so I'd say
slightly more than a quantitation
workflow
um but really not not too much
great
this next question here asks do
libraries have to be collected on the
same instrument for example can I share
my psyx library with someone using an
Agilent cutoff
yeah
um so the answer is no
um so uh it depends a little bit uh on
what format the libraries in so if
you're library is in one of the open
source formats so let's take Mona for
example in the mono Library there's data
that was collected on you know science
instruments Agilent Waters Thermo all of
all of the vendors and we can query that
just the same so it really just depends
on what format your library is not the
instrument itself that it was collected
on
great
and next question here what if a
standard doesn't exist
that's a tough spot
um and it's a spot that you likely can
end up in so if a standard doesn't exist
you have a couple options you can try to
synthesize that standard which is
expensive and it's going to take a long
time or you can decide what you know it
what was the purpose of this
um if the purpose was to
ID and new compound
um and you know this is an important
safe and synthetic drug maybe
synthesizing it does make sense
but if you screened the sample and this
was let's say uh
some sort of impurity that maybe you
found in a common pharmaceutical maybe
that's not important enough for you to
go through that process so
the answer is it's going to take some
time and it really depends on what
you're trying to answer
great well we will go ahead and wrap up
there so I want to thank you again Carl
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor psyx for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye